hi I'm Eric Boston Avengers end game
must be setting up a game changer for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe with
spider-man far from home suggesting that
apparently people who die don't always
stay dead yep welcome to the world of
comics general public where our steaks
are served medium nonexistent and it's
not just a dusted characters like Loki
and Gamora who died dustless deaths wet
deaths the gross do apparently have
futures in the Marvel Universe some
hints on social media and leaks set
photos saying that they might be an end
game so what does this mean for our old
pal Quicksilver the freshman Avenger who
died way back in age of Ultron could he
ever come back let's dig into this
question and for the warning in case I
accidentally reveal anything big and
ruin your life okay a lot of this
speculation began shortly after infinity
war came out when some rumors claim to
have spotted Quicksilver actor Aaron
taylor-johnson on the Avengers set in
Atlanta Georgia suggesting that he was
participating in reshoots for the next
movie there was some Twitter accounts
some fan sites though I should say -
this was never really confirmed there
weren't any leaked photos of him or
anything is really just gossip and then
some of you have been joining me in my
14 million 605 re watches Avengers
infinity war claimed to have seen a
silvery blue streak zipping around the
battlefield outside Wakanda I guess it
was kind of like a shooting star that
you all wished upon for a Quicksilver to
come back to life Batman no streaks are
really blaster shots or in some cases
maybe Thor's Stormbreaker battle axe
sweeping through last fall Aaron
taylor-johnson was asked of Quicksilver
would ever come back in the MCU and he
responded saying it's not a conversation
right now
so ears might take on this I don't think
Quicksilver will return in Avengers in
games there are just so many characters
already involved with this and I think
that we would have seen some evidence
that Quicksilver would be part of the
movie in some way the way that we've
seen some leaks and tweets are pretty
much everyone else appearing in the
movie and after quicksilver's death an
age of Ultron Marvel head Kevin Feige
stressed that quicksilver's death was
permanent and that the decision to kill
him off was in every draft of Joss
Whedon script for the movie Feige
admitted that they did shoot an altar
and indeed with Quicksilver standing
among the other Avengers but they only
did that to avoid leaks and spoilers
from getting out all this said I don't
think we're done with Quicksilver in the
MCU here's why Dark Phoenix remember
that movie
coming sure the release date was pushed
back again from this month to June but
the whole x-men game from the Fox Marvel
Universe is getting at least one more
movie with Jean Grey struggling to
contain her Phoenix force and how that
affects the relationship with Charles
Xavier magneto Scott Summers and the
rats back when I broke down the trailer
for Dark Phoenix a number of shots of a
funeral pointed to at least one
character dying a close analysis of the
imagery in an application of the process
of elimination led me to predict that
mystique Raven Jennifer Lawrence would
be the one to die she doesn't appear in
the shots that seem to take place after
that funeral or in shots that seem later
in the movie when the x-men are turning
on each other and arguably her death
would have the greatest emotional impact
on several of these characters but
looking back there was one more
character mysteriously missing from a
lot of this trailer one of the best
things to come out of the last two x-men
movies Peter maksimov the x-men version
of Quicksilver played by Evan Peters he
could be the one in the grave in this
trailer that would be a bit of a bummer
because out of all the characters in the
recent x-men movies Quicksilver is
really the one who already feels to me
to be speaking with the tone and the
humor of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he's great it would be awesome if he
could just join the current Avengers
lineup but just think about that play it
out that would set up some really
confused looks from Wanda Maximoff
you'll belong to look like my brother
oh these movies kind of changed my
accent with that explanation you ain't
my brother oh by killing off Quicksilver
in the x-men side of the Cinematic
Universe along with the early dead one
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
studio can reset the character however
they want in the future yes Feige and
everyone involved have quashed these
rumors and Quicksilver his immediate
return but Feige was really saying those
things before the Fox Marvel merger deal
was on the table more recent interviews
have showed this guy looking far more
giddy at the idea of rebooting the x-men
under the Marvel brand if I get really
does want to make Marvel phase four all
about the x-men which i think will be a
pretty good idea of course a new
incarnation of Quicksilver will be under
consideration maybe not as soon as
endgame but definitely sooner than ever
I don't know how much would you prefer
the Evan Peters Quicksilver continuing
in his own capacity in future films even
though it probably wouldn't work to line
him up with the current Avengers or a
completely new rebooted Quicksilver who
and be in Avengers movies coming down
below with your thoughts and follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at a Boston
subscribe to this channel and subscribe
to our new podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts if you use the Himalaya app
we'd really appreciate if you subscribe
through that because the more people who
subbed through Himalaya the more they
can help us release new fun podcast
shows thank you for watching and thanks
especially for sitting through my new
bit of redneck scarlet which way that
tastes good good workshop
[Music]